Hallo. Guten Tag. Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Dr. Frau Tolo. Ich bin als Assistenzerstin hier in der
Station tätig und würde gerne das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache, jemand hilft mir. Ja, Kustumablauf. Ich werde Ihnen ein paar Erfragungen
zu Ihrer Person stellen und kommen wir gleich zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Andreas Schulz. Andreas Schulz. Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam
buchstabieren? Ja, der Vorname ist Andreas A-N-D-R-E-A-S. Andreas, ein Nennnamen, ne? Schulz, S-C-H, U-L-Z.
Z, okay. Und wie alt sind Sie? Noch bin ich 34. 34. Wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 18. Mai 1990.
Und wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,86. 1,86. Und wie viel wegen Sie tot seid?
Ich wiege so 98 Kilo. Und was ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Doktor Schröder. Okay, was führt Sie denn zu uns?
Also, ja, war jetzt die Feiertage vor uns liegen, habe ich gedacht, ich komme jetzt doch mal vorbei.
Ich habe seit Tagen Kopfschmerzen und die werden überhaupt nicht besser. Und das ist hier auf der linken Seite, es brennt irgendwie ganz stark.
Und es hat erst langsam angefangen, deswegen habe ich das erst gar nicht so ernst genommen, ne?
Und jetzt habe ich so einen Zins und brennender im Kopf und es ist ganz, ganz unangenehm.
Und ich habe versucht, Tabletten zu nehmen, ich habe über Profäen genommen. Das hat überhaupt nichts geholfen.
Und dann habe ich mich mal so mit dem Kopf auf ein Wärmekissen gelegt.
Da hatte ich das Gefühl, es ist ein bisschen besser. Aber inzwischen ist es so, dass es also richtig bis hinten in den Kopf und in den Nacken reinzieht und auch in den ganzen Arm reiht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr richtig bewegen. Und alles tut sofort in dem Kopf da oben weh. Es ist ganz furchtbar.
Okay. Und seit wann haben Sie diese Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, das hat vor vier Tagen, hat es langsam angefangen. Und ich bin dann immer noch zur Arbeit gegangen und habe gedacht, wie ein Kopfschmerzen kann es sich jetzt dann nicht fehlen und so.
Aber es wurde dann immer schlimmer.
Sie beschöpft diese Beschwerden brennend, ziehend. Und ist das richtig?
Ja, es ist richtig.
Und nur ein linken Seite des Kopfes beschränkt?
Ja, nur links ist das ja.
Und Sie haben dafür Beprüfen eingenommen. Wie viele Milligramm wissen Sie?
Oh, das sind glaube ich 600, die ich da genommen habe. Ich habe das zweimal probiert, aber da ist eigentlich nicht viel Erleichterung gewesen.
Und die Schmerzen schalten in den Nacken und in den linken Armen, oder?
Ja, also das zieht hier so richtig runter bis in den Armen rein, ja, über die Schulter bis in den Armen rein, ja.
Und haben Sie Krippen und Haupthaltsgefühl oder Lehmungen bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein, nein, nein.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen? Auch eine Schmerzfälle, 1 bis 10, wobei 1 leichte und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen entspricht?
Unerträglich. Na ja, unerträglich sind die Schmerzen nicht, aber sie sind schon heftig.
Ach ja, das ist schwer zu sagen, vielleicht sobald 6.
6. Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen, wissen Sie?
Ich kann mir das nicht erklären, nein, also das fing ja langsam an und seither ist es immer schlimmer geworden, ja.
Und inzwischen ist es auch so, dass ich wirklich, also dass mir richtig ein bisschen schlecht ist und dass ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann, ich mag gar nichts mehr essen, weil der Kopf so weh tut, ja.
Und ja, nachts kann ich auch nicht gut schlafen.
Wegen der Säschmassen?
Ja.
Schlafen.
Und haben Sie Übelkeit?
Ja, überall ist mir das gerade, ne?
Müssten Sie dann übergeben?
Nein, Gott sei Dank nicht, nein, nein, übergeben musste ich mich nicht, aber ich habe so das Gefühl, dass es mich ganz kaputt macht, irgendwie, diese Kopfschmerzen, ja.
Und haben Sie Veränderung in Ihrem Seelvermögen bemerkt, zum Beispiel Doppelzehen oder Augenblitzen vor dem Aufgleich?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, zum Glück nicht.
Sind Ihnen Ohrensausen aufgefallen?
Ohrensausen, nein, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Und wie ist Ihr Gleichgewicht?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das gestört ist.
Müssten Sie, ich bin es mir nicht aufgefallen, dass ich stolper oder irgendwie so, nee, das ist eigentlich alles normal, würde ich sagen.
Und sind Ihnen auffällige eine andere Beschwerde aufgefallen?
Entschuldigung.
Gesundheit.
Danke.
Wie gesagt, also eigentlich nur diese wahnsinnigen Schmerzen, die mich eigentlich so ein bisschen ja auch kaputt machen und diese Übelkeit, dass ich nicht essen mag, aber sonst ja und dass ich halt auch nicht gut schlafen kann.
Also bei der Arbeit fällt es mir halt auch schwer, mich zu konzentrieren, weil ich ständig dieses Gefühl habe, diese Kopfschmerzen, die bohren sich da so durch, ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Masseilassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, da habe ich eigentlich nie Probleme, nee.
Und bekommen Sie Ihre Regelblutung?
Ich bin ein Mann, immer noch.
Entschuldigung.
Andreas, ne?
Nein.
Herr Schuss, entschuldigen.
Und leiten Sie an Vorerkrankungen, die ich wissen sollte?
Also das Einzige, was ich sagen kann, Sie haben ja gemerkt, ich musste gerade niesen, ich habe so eine Pollenallergie und jetzt im Augenblick blüht ja gerade ganz viel, da kriege ich halt Schnupfen und die Augen trennen so ein bisschen, aber eigentlich bin ich ansonsten gesund.
Gesund.
Und nehmen Sie eine Medikamente bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig ein?
Eigentlich nehme ich nix ein, also wenn das mit dem Schnupfen zu doll ist, nehme ich mal so Nasentropfen, aber eigentlich nehme ich so keine Medikamente ein.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte als Kind mal einen Fahrradunfall und da habe ich mir den linken Unterarm gebrochen.
Und da, das musste operiert werden, das musste wieder gerichtet werden und da bin ich dann eben operiert worden.
Haben Sie noch Probleme mit dem Linkner?
Nein, eigentlich ist der gut verheilt oder so.
Ja, jetzt tut er halt weh.
Und Sie haben Pollenallergie und haben Sie noch andere Allergen oder Unverdurchkeiten?
Ja, eigentlich, ich war immer kerngesund. Wie gesagt, diese Schnupfengeschichte, naja, gut, das haben halt einige Leute, aber sonst bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden mit mir.
Ja, ich hatte nie große Probleme.
Okay, das folgt mir.
Und Rauchungsee, Herr Schulz?
Ja, also ich rauch wirklich nur ganz, ganz wenig.
Also eigentlich bin ich so ein Gesellschaftsraucher.
Ja, wenn die Kollegen rausgehende Pause machen, dann gehe ich halt mit und dann rauch ich auch mal eine.
Aber das sind vielleicht so 50er-Retten am Tag, also das ist so gut wie nix.
Seit wann?
Ach ja, wie lange arbeite ich jetzt schon da in dem Büro?
Ja, seit zwölf Jahren.
Da hat es angefangen.
Und schinken Sie auch Alkohol?
Ja, aber jetzt auch keine großen Mengen oder so. Am Wochenende trinke ich mal was, wenn man ausgeht oder wenn es was zu feiern biebt oder wenn irgendwo ein Fest ist, ja, dann trinkt man mal ein Bier oder auch mal ein Glas Wein oder auch mal ein Schnaps mit oder so.
Wirklich, nicht jeden Tag um Gottes Willen, nein.
Und das ist eine Loutinerfrage. Nehmen Sie Drogen ein?
Drogen? Ich? Nee, nee, also das mache ich nicht.
Okay. Und sind Sie Vorstand geimpft?
Ja, also als Kind bin ich natürlich gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten so geimpft worden und dann ja, als diese Covid-Geschichte war, habe ich mich natürlich auch impfen lassen, aber jetzt die letzte Impfung liegt schon ziemlich lange zurück da.
Das ist ja auch schon jetzt fünf Jahre her, diese Covid-Episode da.
Okay. Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Na ja, also mein Vater, der hatte, der hatte wo mal Probleme mit dem Herzen, der hat dann vor zwei Jahren einen Stent bekommen, aber seitdem geht es ihm wieder gut und meine Mutter ist eigentlich auch so gesund.
Sie hat jetzt eine Knieprothese mal bekommen, ja, aber das ist auch schon zwei, drei Jahre her, aber damit kommt ihr jetzt gut zurecht.
Welches Knie?
Ich glaube das linke ist es ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester habe ich ja.
Sind Sie gesund auch?
Meine Schwester ist gesund, ja, ja. Ich wüsste nicht, dass der irgendwas fehlt.
Okay. Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig, aber ich lebe mit meiner Freundin zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, Kinder haben wir nicht.
Was machen Sie benuflich?
Ja, ich bin Angestellte im Einwohneramt, also im Bürgeramt.
Angestellte?
Im Einwohneramt, ne?
Was macht man in diesem Beruf eigentlich?
Ja, also wir nehmen alle Anfragen von Bürgern an, die zum Beispiel neue Ausweise beantragen oder Pässe oder die sich ummelden, weil sie umgezogen sind.
Ja, dann muss man sich ja im Bürgeramt melden.
Und ich habe also viel am Computer zu tun, überwiegend eigentlich, fast nur noch.
Haben Sie vermärscht bei der Arbeit in letzter Zeit oder privat?
In letzter Zeit eigentlich, es ist mit dem Stress nicht so schlimm.
Wir hatten mal so ganz anstrengende Zeiten, aber im Augenblick läuft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber man zahlt den ganzen Tag am Computer und bei Schimmwetter möchte man lieber rausgehen.
Und Kostüm Ihrer Beschwerden, hatten Sie in der Beschwerden Vergangenheit?
In der Vergangenheit?
Also ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich mal so eine Kopfschmerzattacke hatte.
Also auch, dass das überhaupt nicht besser wird.
Und jetzt schon tagelang anhält, das kenne ich überhaupt nicht.
Und haben Sie noch diese Schmerz?
Ja, im Augenblick.
Und möchten Sie von uns eine Schmerzmittel?
Ja, irgendwas, was hilft, wäre natürlich gut.
Bisher hat ja nichts geholfen.
Okay.
Und ich bin fertig mit dem Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Ja, was mal dagegen tun, woher kommt denn das, dass mit einmal diese Kopfschmerzen so hartnäckig sind?
Ja, ich werde zuerst Ihnen körperlich untersuchen und Brut abnehmen und MRT Ihre Kopfes veranlassen.
Dann bespreche ich mit meinem Oberarzt und komme Ihnen zurück und teile Ihnen, was du tunst.
Teilen Sie mir mit.
Ja, ja, ja, da muss ich jetzt erst mal die nächsten Stunden hier in der Klinik bleiben.
Ja, um diese, all diese Untersuchungen durchführen, müssen Sie ein paar Stunden bei der Klinik bleiben.
Und ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, wo kann ich denn jetzt warten?
In der Wartezimmer, nächstes Thema können Sie warten und...
Gut, dann setz ich mich dahinten und Sie kommen dann gleich zu mir, ne?
Okay.
Ja, okay, das war ja schon schön.
Hat irgendjemand von Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie über Empfindlichkeit gegen bestimmte Geräusche oder Licht?
Nein.
Hat die Frau Dr. Tugel, hat nach Blitze sehen und Augenstörungen, hat sie gefragt, aber sie hat nicht auszudrücken,
nach Überempfindlichkeit gefragt, aber kann ich im Augenblick nicht darüber berichten?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke.
Hülern Sie dich, fieblich?
Fieblich fühle ich mich nicht, nee.
Die Schmerzen sind links.
Das habe ich aber gesagt und da hat sie auch abgefragt, ja.
Haben Sie vielleicht tränende Augen?
Nee, also nur durch den Schnupfen jetzt, ja.
Nackensteifigkeit.
Das ist natürlich jetzt ja...
Er sagt ja, dass die Schmerzen in den Nacken und in die Schulter ausstrahlen.
Und natürlich tut es weh, aber dass der richtig steif ist, nicht, nee.
Gott sei Dank.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit viel abzugenommen oder zuzugenommen?
Ab oder zu genommen mein Gewicht ist, würde ich sagen, seit langer Zeit stabil.
Sind Sie links- oder rechts-Händler?
Ich bin rechtshändler.
Nicht händler, sondern händer, rechtshänder, ja.
Nicht händler, Arschloch.
Dankeschön.
Ja, wenn ich den Kopf drehe, habe ich Schmerzen, ja, genau.
Ja, das ist ja der Klassiker, ne?
Wenn man, also, ja, kennt man doch eigentlich nicht, dass man so...
Dass man dann, was hast du gesagt, ne?
Ja, man kann sich so mit dem ganzen Körper um, weil man den heißlich so drehen kann, ja.
Haben Sie schwindelig oder schwindelig Gefühle?
Ja, haben Sie schwindelig Gefühle, das richtig.
Hat sie, glaube ich, gefragt?
Ja, hat sie gefragt?
Da habe ich aber verneint, ja.
Sie sagen gescheit, Frau Dr. Tucho, wenn wir Arzt abzusprechen machen können, ne?
Okay, können wir anfangen?
Ja, wir auch gerne.
Was ich irgendwie noch sagen will, Sie waren ja perfekt in der Zeit, ne?
Aber das ist natürlich auch nicht so ein wahnsinnig komplexer Fall.
Aber Sie waren wie ist es, ne?
Ja, gut, jetzt machen wir als Arztgespräch.
Danke.
Guten Sonntag, Frau Oberarztin.
Heute haben wir eine neue Patiente und ihr Fall möchte ich gerne mit Ihnen besprechen.
So, bitte, es ist ein Mann, Andreas.
Ja, sein Fall.
Ja, sicher.
Okay.
Und der Patient heißt Andreas Schult.
Er ist 34 Jahre alt.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen linksseitiger Brennende,
ziehenden Kopfhalschie vorgestellt.
Der Patient Tucho, der hat sich vorgestellt,
der Patient Tufolge,
die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten seien.
Also dem Patient Tufolge seien die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten, ja?
Danke, ja.
Er habe dagegen Epochrofen 800 mg eingenommen,
aber habe das nicht geholfen.
Und die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 von 10 angegeben.
Darüber hinaus gab er als Begleitende Überkeit
und Konzentrationsstörung wegen der Schmerzen.
Und das Fieber und Vomitus und Fasser und Entschuldigung.
Die Frage nach Fieber wurde von der Patientin verneint.
In der vegetativen Anamnese gab sich die vegetativen Anamnese
unauffällig bis auf Schmerzbedingte in Appetenz und Insomnie.
Der Patient habe keine Vorerkrankungen und er nehme wegen
der Schmerzen, die Polynalenasen-Tropfen bei Bedeib ein.
Bei ihm, als Kind,
wurde eine Osteosanthese des Wienkenarmes durchgeführt worden,
zur Stammung nach einem Fahrradunfall.
Bei ihm eine Polynalenasen-Tropfen-Allergie und die Allergie
mit Heuschnupfen.
Der Patient sei vorstandig geimpft.
Er sei rocher.
Er war seit zwölf Jahren fünf Skateten täglich, das heißt,
drei Packiers.
Er trinkte Alkohol nur am Wochenende oder besonderen Annesten,
ein Bier oder ein Glas Wein.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde vor dem Patient verneint.
Von dem Patienten in der Klinese.
In der Familienanamnese gab sich die folgende Erkrankungen.
Der Vater habe vor zwei Jahren eine Stunt bekommen.
Was für ein Stunt?
Ein Corona-Stunt bekommen.
Die Mutter habe vor zwei bis drei Jahren eine Knie-Tep-Oklation durchgeführt.
Weil der Mutter eine Knie-Tep durchgeführt wurde.
Er hat eine Schwester und sei gesund.
Er sei ledig, aber lebe mit seinen Freunden.
Er sei angestellter Einwohneramtberuf.
Er sitze lange Zeit vor dem Computer wegen der Arbeit.
Der Arbeit hat einen Computer-Arbeitsplatz.
Die an einem nestischen Angaben-Dolten
ist eine HWS-Discus Prolapsin.
Das könnte differenzial diagnostisch noch sein.
Hier kommen eine Migräne und Muskelspannung.
Und Herzinfarkt im Betracht.
Was wäre unter Umständen noch sehr exotisch, aber im Kopf noch möglich?
Ein klasse, weniger schrecklich Blutung.
Das haben sie nicht gefragt, aber es hat auch sonst keiner gefragt.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Ich würde gerne der Patientöpferliche Untersuchung machen.
Worauf gucken Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
In der neurologischen Untersuchung mache ich zuerst.
Ich überpüfe die Nackensteifigkeit.
Ich werde Blut abnehmen.
Ein kleines Blutbild und ein Zündepalmeter,
ich würde es besonders überprüfen.
Ich kontrolliere die Epimeter,
ich messe den Druck und Fieber und Herzdrucken, Atomdrucken.
Ich veranlasse ein EKG, um einen Myocardinfarkt aufzuschließen.
Es gab nicht viel Anzeichen dafür.
Wenn man die Anzeichen für ein Myocardinfarkt werden würde,
müsste man unter Umständen das Gespräch unterbrechen.
Ich finde, ich habe nicht viel geboten.
Ich bin schon nach halbem Schritt weiter.
Sie machen noch einen EKG.
Das hatte ich unwahrscheinlich vor einem Herzinfarkt,
aber wegen des Familienanamnese bei der Patientöpfer.
Die Schmerzen in den linken Armen,
das ist möglich, sicher zu sein.
Ich veranlasse ein EMATI des Kopfes
und gegebenen FACITY unter dem Faktor.
Mit welcher Fragestellung?
Für eine subjektive Teilbelutung
ist das vielleicht eine City des Kopfes zu veranlassen.
Um eine HWS-Discussprolapse auszuschließen,
sollten wir ein EMATI des Nacken.
Sehr gut.
Dann bin ich gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen herauskommt.
Melden Sie sich, sobald Sie sich sicher sind,
was mit dem Patienten los ist.
Wenn er tatsächlich ein HWS-Syndrom hat,
was würde man therapeutisch mit dem anfangen?
Als Erstes würde ich Schmerz Therapie anneiten.
Für die Spannung werde ich ...
Das fehlt mir nicht die Name als sein Zyl.
Ach so, welches Medikament das ist.
Ein kranzlösendes Mittel, denke ich, oder?
Ja.
Was Entspannendes.
Wer haben wir oder Kälteranwendungen?
Wer mich hilft bei ihm.
Und Physiotherapie und Bewegungstherapie.
Und Spaßmonitikum, ja.
So heißt das Wort.
Gut, oder Muskel-Relaxanz.
Ja, wunderbar.
Dann bin ich gespannt.
Gegebenenfalls eine Operation ...
Wenn der einen Bandscheibenvorfall hat.
Ja, in Lester-Stitz.
Gut.
Ja, das war eine sehr schöne Anamnese.
Sie ist sehr flüssig.
Sie haben sehr schön variiert in ihren Fragen.
Sie haben nicht immer, sie haben, sie haben,
sondern sie haben es ihnen aufgefallen, haben sie bemerkt.
Ja, sehr schön.
Das haben sie, fand ich, richtig gut gemacht.
Da waren sie auch sprachlich, sehr souverän.
Beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch ist mir wieder aufgefallen,
ziemlich viel M, nicht ganz so viel, aber schon,
also auch noch relativ häufig.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie eben doch häufig
die Satzstellung nicht ganz korrekt machen.
Und wenn ich die Klassiker, dann, ich werde ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Ja, und das haben sie, also auch beim Bericht über den Patienten,
sie haben sehr konsequent, den Konjunktiv angewendet.
Ja, also nach Angaben des Patienten
bestehend, nie bestünden keine,
bestünden keine, oder,
habe er sich nicht übergeben oder irgendwie.
Also eben da haben sie sehr, sehr konsequent den Konjunktiv angewendet.
Und das ist ja für viele Prüfer sehr wichtig,
diese indirekte Rede praktisch damit zu zeigen.
Aber da haben sie manchmal auch wieder diese Satzstellung
komisch gehabt, dass sie nicht das Verb
an die zweite Position gesetzt haben.
Das fällt mir immer wieder auf,
ist ein gern genommener Fehler.
Ja, was ansonsten war,
Augenblick, Knie-Trophäen, das war alles richtig.
Ja, das Einzige, wo ich noch einen kleinen Fehler gefunden habe,
also vielleicht ein Übertragungsfehler oder so,
sie haben gefragt, was für eine Dosierung Ibuprofen
der Patient eingenommen hat.
Und der hat 600 gesagt und sie haben im Arztbericht,
dann haben sie 800 gesagt.
Aber mit den Zahlen muss man natürlich ein bisschen aufpassen.
Das nehmen Prüfer manchmal ausgesucht übeln,
komischerweise.
Ja, aber, was ich auch schön fand,
dass sie ziemlich konsequent auch Fachbegriffe angewendet haben,
ganz am Anfang haben sie sich noch von Kopfschmerzen gesprochen,
haben sie aber gleich gesagt, ja, Zäphalgie, ja, schön.
Auch das ist so was, was viele Prüfer eben sich wünschen,
dass die Prüflinge in Fachteilmanologie benutzen,
nachvollziehbar.
Ich konnte sie gut verstehen.
Sie konnten mich, glaube ich, auch gut verstehen.
Und wir waren uns relativ einig, würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube, wir können zusammenfassend sagen,
dass das eine sehr schöne Anamnese und ein sehr schönes Arztgespräch war.
Und was war der Fall?
Ist das korrekt HWS-Bandscheiben?
Es ist nur HWS-Syndromes, es ist kein Bandscheibenvorfall.
HWS-Syndromes.
Ja, und das ist halt ja dieser Klassiker,
wenn man den ganzen Tag am Computer sitzt, ja.
Also ich habe das bei der Arbeit auch eine Zeit lang gehabt,
nicht so ausgeprägt, aber praktisch der Auslöser sitzt im Nacken
und dann zieht das halt nach oben.
Und er hat das Gefühl, die Kopfschmerzen sind da
und strahlen nach unten.
Aber letztendlich sitzt es tatsächlich im Nacken
und macht Kopfschmerzen.
Und das eskaliert ja, das wird ja immer schlimmer.
Je weniger man sich bewegt, desto steifer wird man.
Und dann kann man eben nachher nur noch so mit anderen Leuten reden,
dass man sich so mit dem ganzen Körper rumdreht.
Und ja, sobald man ein bisschen den Kopf verlagert,
auch im Bett zum Beispiel beim Liegen,
hat man das Gefühl, es hält einem gleich der Kopf ab.
Und die...
Ja, der alte Held, Wärme und Massage und Bewegung und ja, gut.
Ich denke mal, das war schön.
Und sie haben nichts ausgelassen, alles komplett gefragt.
Ja, also das ist vielleicht noch diese eine Sache,
was wir unterwegs jetzt eingefallen ist,
dass sie nicht nach einem Trauma gefragt haben, ja.
Also der hat ja gesagt, der hat starke Kopfschmerzen.
Dann wäre vielleicht auch noch so eine Methode,
haben sie sich irgendwo die Birne angestoßen, ja.
Aber ja, das wäre auch vielleicht die einzige Erklärung
für eine Blutung.
Warum soll sonst ein junger Mann eine Hirnblutung haben, ja.
Aber ja, wäre denkbar,
wenn der was, was ich in normalen Fahrradunfall hatte oder so, ja.
Oder ja, oder sich irgendwo bei der Gartenarbeit den Kopf gestoßen hat.
Gut, nee, aber ich glaube, sie können sehr zufrieden sein,
ja, alle können zufrieden sein
und können getrost in die Feiertage starten.
Ja, danke.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen ein schönes Wochenende
und heute einen guten, ruhigen, entspannten Abend,
eine ruhige Nacht.
Und wir sehen uns am nächsten Dienstag
und dann schauen wir, was es weiter gibt, ja.
Gut, ja, danke schön.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen schöne Feiertage.
Machen Sie es gut und bis Dienstag.
Ja, tschüss.